well hey y'all good morning how are you
doing today I hope you're doing alright
I I'm still feeling a little bit
jet-lagged myself I just had some kind
of little tiny piece of you know a
little cup of some kind of magic and now
I can hear colors as amazing caffeine
they got out there I'm so excited to be
here at another in DC Sydney and to
present to you some information on
electron building cross-platform desktop
apps with electron this is a technology
that I've been using for for several
years now to solve lots of little
problems or build utilities and so forth
and I I think it's a fun and fantastic
technology to work with so what we're
covering today is what is electron why
do we won't even want to consider
building desktop apps in this web first
mobile first world that we live in today
give you a crash course on how to get
started with electron and some tips of
to help you get started that I've
learned through my experience so far so
to start off with I want to tell you a
story about how you know I got started
with electron so I for a long time I was
on the Microsoft stack stack of
technologies I was at the Microsoft PDC
in 2000 when net was announced and they
gave everybody at that conference a
little book called presenting c-sharp
and this was also the time when when
c-sharp was unveiled being the nerd that
I am I went back to my hotel room that
night and I read that little book
presenting c-sharp from from cover to
cover and I thought this is this is it I
love this this is the language I want to
get behind and this is the next
evolution of web development for the
Microsoft platform and I was I was
gung-ho so for the longest time
I was a microsoft.net fanboy and when
the time came that I needed to build a
app that was cross-platform
I knew that my the mobile team at the
company I was working at was having
great success building mobile apps with
xamarin and I and I had heard that there
was a SAM Rijn desktop app that you
could use to build desktop tools and you
could also build some command-line tools
as well and I thought well that's what
I'll do I'll use my mad dot net skills
and build some cross-platform desktop
apps and and I'll knock this out of the
park so what I found in that experience
was that as I tried to build some some
desktop apps is that yes you can't have
some shared dotnet code between the
different versions of the apps but
that's pretty much where the benefits
ended xamarin Mac at least at the time I
don't know if it's still the case but it
did not get the same amount of love that
the iOS and Android apps
get and it was you know very buggy and
very hard to work with the documentation
was not great native UI was extremely
hard because be being a web developer I
don't know anything about building
desktop apps and so having to you know
if you're building for Windows you have
to use WPF or our wind forms on the Mac
you have to build your UI using Xcode UI
builder and if you're building for Linux
god help you
and so xamarin doesn't solve these you
know that issue it doesn't give you like
a unified way of building UI or front
ends for for your desktop app so it's
you're on your own to build those in you
know kind of the native tools deployment
was also not trivial
on Windows you've got the advantage of
having the dotnet framework that you can
deploy your apps to but on Mac and Linux
having to distribute mono or to have
mono built for for those other platforms
it's is not an easy thing to do and at
the time this was before Microsoft had
acquired xamarin so licensing was a
deal-breaker for me as a thousand
dollars a year for a license for xamarin
just for the xamarin Mac and that was
that was too much to swallow for the the
kinds of one-off utilities and things
that I needed to create that I wasn't
going to be selling these were just you
know to help some customers so my
experience through those those few weeks
that I tried you know flailing
desperately to make this work it was a
lot of frustration so I heard about this
thing called electron and I thought I'd
give it a try and the pros are that it's
a CH tml CSS and JavaScript I those are
things that technologies that I
understand being a web developer I know
how to build front ends with with that
so being able to use you know the kinds
of front-end technologies that I'm
comfortable with to build a desktop app
that's a very appealing to me electron
is built on nodejs and chrome which is
which is pretty cool you know no js' has
gotten very popular and it's something
that I you know as a web developer I
started getting more and more into and
that was appealing to me and there are
no deployment dependencies when building
an electron application when you package
your application together you have a
basically a standalone app that it
doesn't require your your users or your
customers to have some version of node
installed or even have chrome installed
you know it's all self-contained and you
can deploy it as is and the another cool
thing about being node and chrome is
that it's very you're targeting a very
one of the latest versions of node and
chrome
your applications your building you're
not having to worry about cross browser
compatibility issues between Chrome and
Firefox and ie your edge you know you're
you're targeting specific versions of
node in Chrome and it's really it's it's
pretty awesome the the experience I had
you know even in the very beginning was
it was it was easy to pick up easy to
use and I had you know immediate success
in building some applications and as I
mentioned before you're targeting you
know the latest versions of node and
Chrome or the v8 engine that comes with
chrome and node and so you can use the
latest es6 s7 whatever latest javascript
features that are available for those
platforms so you can use you know fat
our arrow syntax you can now use async
and await you can use you know promises
if you want to use promises but all the
language features that have been added
over the last few years you have access
to that without having to use a
transpiler like babel and which is which
is really awesome so i've been remiss
not to mention you know that there are
you know electron is not a silver bullet
there are some drawbacks to electron and
the drawback is that it's it's HTML CSS
and JavaScript so if you're not already
a web developer you know that can be a
bit of a challenge for you but there's
there's just so much out there that's
available to to help make you successful
as far as front-end technologies and
examples in JavaScript and you can take
advantage of the whole node ecosystem to
help build your desktop applications so
a little history about electron it was
first created by github for the atom
editor and it was formerly it was
originally named the atom shell and to
reduce confusion as to what you could do
with this this technology they renamed
it to electron so that people could know
that they could build more than just
editors with it it's been around since
2013 has been
actively developed the 1.0 release was
in 2016 and just to like a yesterday or
two days ago I don't know my my time
zones and everything are all mixed up
but just recently 3.0 was released and
which means I had to go and update all
my demos last night anyway it's very
cool they they have continued to improve
and make building new features and
capabilities into the electron framework
and it's shows no signs of slowing down
some of the features that are available
there's a rapid development I mean that
makes it really easy to to prototype and
to build a desktop application there's a
number of properly no hard problems with
desktop apps that they have already
solved for you with electron and that
includes deployments and silent updates
so it's kind of built into the framework
the ability to have your Apple have your
electron application running somewhere
and have it be able to check for for new
versions of the application and download
those versions and prompt the user to
restart - and to upgrade your
application there's a number of native
UX extensions that are built into
electron that make your electron
applications seem like debt you know
native desktop apps so things like the
menus dialogues like file open and save
and printer dialogues all those are
native to each operating system that the
application runs on so someone who is
using your application wouldn't you know
probably never know that it was a web
app you know it looks like looks and you
can make it look and feel as much of a
native application as as you want you
can definitely have shared code and UI
between you know since its HTML and
JavaScript chances are if you have an
existing web application and you want to
take some some of the guts of that
application and port it over to a
desktop app
you can probably leverage a lot of the
the code and and things that you already
have if it's you know around the front
end of JavaScript or even if you're
using node on the back end and just like
you know there's one of the one of the
popular things today is being able to
customize your applications you know
giving your customers the ability to you
know make it look and feel like like
they want since it is HTML and CSS you
can easily swap out style sheets to give
your customers the ability to change
them at like a light or dark theme or
even to do rebrand your applications to
different vertical markets so if you
want to go after one industry you know
and then rebrand it and go after another
industry is it's just swapping out some
CSS and you know some a few assets
electron is agnostic as far as what it
what front-end technology you want to
use you can use whatever you want you
can use plain HTML and JavaScript you
can use you know jQuery or you can use
any of the popular front-end frameworks
with it there's no limit to you know
what what you want to use are what
you're comfortable with you can use that
those front-end tools to help build
desktop apps so why do we want to create
desktop applications in this world that
we live today I think there are a number
of use cases a number of scenarios that
the desktop apps still make sense if you
need offline capabilities like you know
an application that can go into the
field and be able to do data entry or
processing of information or just being
able to run disconnected from the
internet you know there's there you know
lots of scenarios where that makes sense
there's a being able to access local
hardware like printers and devices
scanners readers if you're building an
application it's that needs to be able
to operate that kind of those those
kinds of devices you know a desktop app
usually makes a little more sense
building on premises
applications so this was my use case
when the company I used to work for was
a cloud company SAS product and to build
integrations between other platforms and
our product we needed to have some tools
or utilities that could run on premise
with the at the customer because we
couldn't expect the customer to open up
their firewall and let us reach in and
grab their data and synchronize it with
ours we needed an agent that could run
you know in there on their network so
that it could communicate with their
their applications and and communicate
through back to us using our api's and
this worked really well internal line of
business applications being able to edit
local files maybe you want to take an
application use our idea or something's
you've created and try to monetize that
in the App Store electrons supports both
the Windows and the Mac App Store's you
want to build kiosk type applications
where you know in a retail or healthcare
scenario where someone walks up to a
screen and the application that's on the
screen is all they have you know it's
full screen they don't have a way to
break out of that application that's all
that they interact with you can build
that kind of application with electron
and sometimes depending on you know the
type of company that you work for maybe
desktop is is a whole lot easier to
build apps for then then deploy
something to the intranet you know I've
worked places where there was so much
you know red tape to to be able to
deploy something to an intranet site
whereas maybe I've got three people that
need to use my application I can just
put it on a flash drive and hand it to
them and say hey here's my application
you can you can run it which is probably
terrifying to IT people sometimes like I
said it just it just kind of feels right
there another cert there's classes of
applications that just feel right as a
desktop
not to say that there aren't web
versions of some of those apps but still
people prefer like a mail client you
know sometimes people just really prefer
a desktop mail client compared as
opposed to a web app and so here are
some desktop ideas I just brainstorm I'm
not going to go through the full list
but you know these are some different
scenarios of where desktop apps may be
the right solution they may just feel
right like one of those things is a I
remember there was a for awhile there
was an electron application for doing
database management there was
cross-platform you could do sequel
server and oracle and my sequel and you
know that's the kind of thing where you
wouldn't want that to be a web app you
that you know to for that kind of tool
to be a web app means you would have to
open up your firewall and let that web
app to communicate with your your
database servers that's not going to
happen right so you need something
that's running on your desktop that can
communicate with those those systems
some examples of electron applications
and you know I've mentioned atom this is
what electron was built for and for a
while you know Adam was a really
fantastic you know kid on the block for
an editor you know I know some people
who still use it and it is a fantastic
editor slack is what got my attention
when I found out that slack was
essentially a web app running on my
desktop it blew my mind and of course
you know on the other end of the
spectrum we all know that slack you know
is is kind of a bit of a memory hog and
gives electron I'm a bit of a bad name
now but I mean it is a very impressive
desktop application this is what has
really gotten a lot of people's
attention when I when I first saw Visual
Studio code I thought well how did
Microsoft pull off building a
cross-platform desktop app with dotnet
because that was my assumption right
it's like you know no way that
Microsoft's going to use something other
than their own
you know platform for building something
and as I dug into it and found out that
it was an electron application that
really blew my mind you know it really
is a new Microsoft they're using you
know essentially nodejs and chrome well
it kind of makes sense now you know fast
forward a few years and now now
Microsoft has acquired or in the process
of acquiring github you know now it kind
of makes kind of makes a little bit more
sense postman is another electron
application that I is one of my
favorites if you do anything with api's
if you support api's or build api's this
application is an invaluable tool that
you can use to test and manipulate or
use different api's and get a desktop
than the latest version of github
desktop is is now an electron
application pretty impressive so how to
electron in a nutshell you're gonna need
avert some version of node installed on
your computer version 4 or later it
doesn't have to be the same version of
node that's that's packaged with you
know the current version of electron as
long as it's version 4 or higher you're
you're good to go you're going to create
a project folder for your desktop
application and inside that folder you
want to run npm install electron npm is
one of the modules is the module package
manager that comes with node that allows
you to install dependencies and and of
course it's named electron once you have
that you need a couple of files you need
a main j/s as your kind of your entry
point into your application and you need
at least one HTML file to load and this
is the the bare bones all that you need
to create your first HelloWorld
application in electron a little bit
about how electron works is you start
off with a electron application starts
its life cycle as a node.js
process and so you have mange a s or you
know you can name it whatever you want
to you can name it start je s or server
J as the name doesn't doesn't matter but
it the lifecycle starts as a main
process in node and in electron
vocabularies they call this the main
process or just process and from there
you can launch one or more instances of
chromium in chrome is the the rendering
engine that renders the UI and these in
electron vocabu-larry vocabu-larry are
called renderers and you can you can
launch more than one if you have an
application that has multiple windows
you can you know launch those windows
you can show and hide those windows as
you need to you can do you know whatever
you need to do so I've shown you a
little bit about how to get started with
electron I want to show you just how
easy it is to to build your first
application so a main jas typically
looks a lot like this we require in the
electron module so in nodejs require is
is equivalent to like an imports or a
using statement this is how a pull in
dependencies in into the the current
application for running so once we have
electron then we can grab a couple of
objects off of that electron object app
and browser window this is d structuring
this is a you know a javascript language
fee you know recent javascript language
feature that we can take advantage of so
instead of saying
const app equals electron dot app and
const browser window equals electron
browser window we can just combine it
into one line and and pull it off at
once and then electron has a number of
our the app object in electron has a
number of lifecycle events so kind of
like jquery if you've ever used jQuery
document.ready
you know the app ready app on ready
event is to let us know that the
internals of electron have finished you
know their initialization and now you're
ready it's ready to for you to start
taking over and and building building
out whatever it is that you need so in
the ready event we can create an
instance of our main window and we can
specify things like the width and height
of that window but there are lots and
lots of properties that we can set on
that window like the position the
minimum and maximum Heights and widths
we can we can turn resize ability on and
off we can set that kiosk mode so it it
launches it full screen and the user
can't do anything to to exit out of that
that window and then finally we can call
main window load URL to load in our file
our index.html file or whatever we name
it into that window that we've created
index dot HTML can be as simple as you
know plain HTML and in this case if we
go to our command line and run in px
electron and mange a s it will launch
our hello world application and it will
look like look like this if it's running
on the Mac it looks you know the chrome
around it the UI looks like a Mac app if
we run this on Windows it's going to
look like a Windows app the the cool
thing to pack with the point out is that
whatever we set and the title of the
HTML becomes the title of that window
and whatever we put in the body of the
HTML becomes the body or becomes the
contents of the the the desktop window
but this is the really cool thing about
electron when I when I started using
electron my assumption was well it's no
js' I've got it I've got to create some
kind of node server running in the
background and communicate between my
front-end I'm thinking in terms as a web
developer I'm thinking I've got to make
a Jack's calls back to some fake server
running on the desktop that's not the
case at all and
electron you have the full power of node
at your fingertips inside your HTML and
JavaScript your front-end JavaScript so
I can add a script tag to my HTML page
and start to use nodejs libraries and
other external libraries that I've
brought in using NPM so process is a
nodejs object that I can use to access
things like the running environment and
lots of things so I can I can check the
versions of node and electron and chrome
that are in there and then this is this
is the power of electron is that I can
require in any module any native module
with a width node or any external module
that I bring in so in this case I'm
requiring in the filesystem module
that's built in the node and I'ma
numerating the the folder files and
folders that are in the home directory
of of the current user that there that's
running the application so electron
extends node with a number of shortcuts
like this process dot environment at
home which points to the home folder of
the current user and it's going to point
at the right home folder when it's
running on Mac and the right home folder
when it's running on Windows and Linux
so it gives you one API that you can use
that is going to be it's going to work
you know across all the different
environments from operating systems that
the code runs and again I can use like
the fat arrow syntax too because I'm not
I'm using the latest version of node in
there and I can take advantage of
JavaScript language features and so I'll
run this application I can see that it's
launching with node 10.2 and electron 3
in chromium 66 and it's listed all the
the folders that are that's in my my
home folder
one tip while we're here is that you can
oh since it is chromium that we're
dealing with we can open the chrome dev
tools with our desktop application so in
this case I'm when I'm launching the app
I can open the dev tools and I've got
different modes I can use detach or I
can attach it to the right side of this
other window or the bottom of the window
there's different modes there that you
can use and so if you if you're a web
developer you're probably familiar with
the chrome dev tools you can use the
same chrome dev tools to inspect and
debug the front-end code for your
electron application so you can set
breakpoints you can step through and
inspect nodes and and all that kind of
stuff pretty cool look at your call
stacked and everything so you may have
heard this this joke there are too hard
problems in software development cache
invalidation naming things and
off-by-one errors right well I submit to
you that there are four hard problems in
software development I don't know what
your development lifecycle is like in
your organization but something I've
discovered that's really really critical
to building applications over the last
few years is choosing the right animated
gif to go along with you know how you
react to your your co-workers pull
requests and code reviews and you know
it's it's really important to have you
know the right animated gifts to go
along with your your responses
especially in slack and of course if you
slack which I'm sure most of you do
giffy is just the worst it's it's just
categorically bad you know no matter
what you do it's gonna it's gonna pick
the worst option available so I built an
electron application called reactor that
helps me to choose the perfect animated
gif to express how I feel about you know
things that are going on and slack or
things that are
you know the code review that I'm making
so this is a pretty good pick
you know anime to give a Spock but I
don't think it quite captures how I
really feel about this person's code
that I'm reviewing so yeah I think that
one does it I think that's a that's a
good analogy to how I feel about this
code so I can click on the the button to
copy it to my clipboard and paste that
into slack or github or wherever I need
to use this this animated gif I believe
this is the most important application
I've created in my career you can find
this on my github repo again it's called
a reactor it's a lot of fun alright so
there are modules that are included with
electron the electron has extended node
with a number of modules that help you
to build your desktop application so
there are some modules that are
available to the main process some that
are available to the renderers and some
that are available to both so in the
process you've got the app which we've
we've already seen it's got application
lifecycle events you can parse
command-line arguments you can access
things like what are the paths to
different folders like the application
folder or the user home folder you can
of course launch instances of browser
windows there's a IPC which is
inter-process communications so to be
able to communicate between the
instances of chromium and your main
process you use IPC is kind of like a
channel publish/subscribe metaphor so
you can create channels and and
subscribe to them and publish messages
and send messages back and forth there's
a dialogue which is gives you the native
file open and save printer dialogues and
you know informational dialogues there's
a menu API that allows
to create in an agnostic way all the
menus for your application so on the Mac
it'll render you know the correct
looking Native menus and on Windows it
creates the menus inside the window
itself all that kind of stuff
there's a power monitor which not only
allows you to know if the applicant
operating system is running on battery
or running on AC you can have events
where you know is the laptop being shut
down or is it going you know is going
into hibernate mode and you can take
action based on those events also you
can you can prevent events like the
screensaver kicking in maybe you're
building a media application and you
need to be able to show training videos
as part of your application you don't
want those videos to be interrupted by
by the computer going to sleep or the
computer or the screensaver kicking in
so you can prevent those things from
happening while your videos are running
there's a tray module for doing things
like tray notifications the though
bubbles or the tray that's at the top of
the mac OS icons and on the renderer
side you've also got IPC for
communicating messages back to the main
process you've got a special version of
IPC called remote which is kind of like
here's here's a command here's a here's
some code that I want you to run on the
main process web frame which is a kind
of like an iframe it behaves like an
iframe and but this is a a sandboxed
frame so back when I showed you the load
URL where you can load in a local HTML
file that's what you want to do but you
maybe as a prototype you can point that
to an external HTML page but that's a
that's a bit of a security concern for a
desktop application you don't want to
let just load in any arbitrary
content even if you own you know you are
the author or I'll own that website you
don't want there may be a
man-in-the-middle attack kind of
scenario you just don't want to
arbitrarily pull in you know HTML and
JavaScript you know from from a source
where you may not be guaranteed is
coming from the right place so this web
frame is the ability to pull in external
content but it's sandboxed so that it
doesn't have access to node and the
other things that you could you know
potentially be used for malicious
purposes so web frame is is Samba
sandbox just like any HTML any browser
just like chrome running so that's
that's helpful modules that are
available to both you've got a clipboard
which allows you to copy things to and
from the clipboard there's a built in
crash reporter so you can if your
application crashes you can post
information to an end point there's a
native image module allows you to do
like handle different DPI's retina
displays or high DPI windows displays
this is useful for like icons that you
use for tray notifications or things
that are running in the tray you can
have different resolutions of those
icons or handle different versions of
images to display there's a screen
module that not only allows you to
enumerate the displays that are
connected to the the current operating
system but also see things like where's
the cursor located and be able to
support multiple monitors so you can
launch an application on once you know a
window on one screen and another window
on a different screen so you can take
advantage of the multiple monitors that
are available then there's a shell which
allows you to launch external
applications you can launch like the
default application for a PDF reader so
like if you want to open a PDF you can
just use the shell module and whatever
is registered on that operating system
as the PDF
application will that'll load up or if
you want to bundle some command line app
tools with your application and run
those in the background you can do that
as well
or you can launch you can certainly use
nodes child processes to launch things
running in the background deploying
electron applications is there there's
lots of scenarios the most simple is you
can take the electron binaries that are
pulled down from from NPM and combine
those with your HTML and CSS and
JavaScript files and just hand that off
to to someone who needs to run your
application you can just you know
basically essentially copy those files
to a flash drive and give them to
somebody else and they can run your
application there's no there's nothing
to install right as I mentioned before
there's no no external dependencies it's
all self-contained now the icon that's
going to be visible when they run the
application is going to look like an
electron application or an electron icon
so the branding and stuff is all
electron if you want to create your your
own app application then you can take
that a step further and use electron
packager and that's going to take your
the the version of electron that you're
building with plus your HTML and CSS and
JavaScript and it's going to create an
app file or an exe for Windows and you
know and you can add in your own assets
with that so you can use your own
desktop icon and and name the windows
and and so forth to to look like your
own application so then you can just
copy those files and and and give them
to someone and or zip those up so that's
that's kind of like what I've done in
the past is just create a zip file of
all these files and allow someone to
download it and extract it and run
run the executable you can also take
that another step further and use
electron builder which will take the the
build step of the electron packager and
then turn around and create an installer
for your application so you know you get
that get that installer experience on
Windows you get a you know that kind of
window experience where on the Mac where
you drag your application into the
Applications folder you know it's it
gives you what you would expect on each
operating system and on Linux it gives
you a debian package that you can deploy
and and and run to install and if you
combine that with electron updater which
is a kind of a nice wrapper around the
updates and silent deployment
capabilities that's built into electron
that gives you a great way of hosting a
a server or an endpoint are you
complaining that a github repository you
can there's a number of options that you
can point electron updater to to say
here's where to go and check for more
updated versions of the application and
if it finds one it goes ahead and
downloads it and gives you a
notification that a new version is
available so if you've used Visual
Studio code you know that sometimes when
you run the application there's a little
notification that pops up at the top
that says the new version is available
do you want to apply and restart to to
apply that that new version now you can
provide that same kind of experience to
people who are using your application
some recommended tools electron debug
gives you the ability to have those some
keyboard shortcuts built-in where you
can launch the chrome dev tools when
your application is running so usually
include this with my electron
application so if someone you know if
it's an internal application then
somebody calls me and says hey there's a
you know I'm having an issue with the
application I can tell them to hit f12
or the command shift I or whatever to
pop up the the chrome dev tools and say
you know let's let's look in the console
and see if there are any JavaScript
errors and that kind of thing and we can
walk through it together as you're
building desktop as you're building
electronic Asian's instead of having to
shut down the the desktop application
and you know - and then reload it again
for every change that you make electron
reload is is kind of like hot reload for
your web applications it monitors your
project folder for any changes to HTML
and CSS and JavaScript files and if it
detects a change to one those files it
automatically reloads or refreshes the
the window so that you can keep on
developing and you know changing and
tweaking your application without having
to shut it down and restart it again if
you do testing if you've used like I've
I've been using nodejs for four years
now and the tool that I prefer is as
mocha or at least in the past I used a
lot of mocha so electron mocha is a
drop-in replacement for mocha that
understands the the libraries that are
made available in the electron
application so that you can you know you
can test with the modules that are
available to an electron there's a
couple of built-in things now and then
in the later versions of electron dev
Tron is a a chrome debug extension that
gives you things like inter-process
communications where you can you can
monitor the different messages that are
going back and forth between your
renderers and main process it gives you
a built-in linter and suggest things
that you can do to improve your your
desktop applications there are spec Tron
which is a built on Chrome driver and
webdriver IO
for doing like front end behavior
testing with your application and to get
getting started with electron I always
suggest that you you build some an
application or - without any you know by
going through the documentation and
going through the steps I've got an
electron workshop that I've done that's
you know about four hours long that's on
my github repo and it steps you through
you know all the things that we've
talked about plus a lot more
it covers debugging covers you know
Enterprise creating inter-process
communications creating menus all the
basic things that you need to create an
electron application I I recommend that
you start there first so that you
understand what electron is doing and at
that point after you've got that kind of
under your under your belt then you can
look at something like an electron
boilerplate that packages up a lot of
those things for you the mistake that I
feel like I made when I when I got
started with electron is that I started
with an elaborate plate project but I
didn't know what the you know the the
problems that I ran into I didn't know
if there was problems with the boiler
plate or problems with electron I had it
I was just really confused so but once
you have some you know the fundamentals
of how electron works the boiler plate
projects are pretty awesome they have
you know things around packaging and
deployments that make it really easy to
brand your application as you want it
and they they add some nice utilities
along the way so there's electron boiler
plate is kind of a front-end agnostic
boiler plate so you can add whatever you
want to on top of that there's there's
also boiler plates for just about any
front-end frameworks those react and
angular and view if there's some other
front-end framework that you use there's
prop there may be a another electron
boiler plate for that so those are great
ways to get started
are great ways to take your application
to the next level there are one really
cool utility called electron pre-built
compiled this is a drop-in replacement
for the electron runtime that gives you
it essentially has babel and typescript
and draft ql and a number of other
things built into the runtime so you can
build things that are beyond the current
version of node that you know the
language features or if you want to use
typescript you can just it it treats
these things as native native type
things so it just understands this stuff
out of the box and it it knows how to
work with react how to use less and sass
how to use J templates how to use a view
components it's it's just a really nice
you know if you're using any of those
kinds of things or think you will then
it's a nice drop-in replacement that
that just allows you to do those things
without having to have a compile step or
a build step here's a couple examples of
some applications that I've created with
electron so I this application in
particular is I use jQuery and I believe
Twitter bootstrap I'm not a designer but
you know for this particular application
I felt like the the font awesome icons
that come with Twitter bootstrap and you
know the nice stylings and everything I
thought it you know the application this
this app only took me two weeks to
create and most of that was you know the
the report generation side of it not the
not the front end or are the tools that
that the desktop gave me there's a CSS
framework called photon kit that helps
you the skin your electron application
so right now it makes your applications
look like a really beautiful Mac app so
if you build an app with photon and
deploy it to Windows it looks like a
really
for Mac app running on Windows which is
pretty cool I don't have a problem with
that so this is an application that I
created using photon kit and it you know
it styles the you know dropdowns and
checkboxes and and all those kind of
elements to make it look more like a Mac
application I think long term the goal
is to add windows UI elements to the
photon kit and it can you know I think
it's under beta but you can you don't
have to do anything to make it look
native on either either operating system
you just it's going to render in the
correct way some tips I know on the Mac
when when you're in the browser Safari
or Chrome or whatever and you mouse you
move your mouse over a hyperlink or
something that's clickable the cursor
turns into what looks like a cartoon
hand people don't expect that in a
desktop application so you can set this
the default cursor and CSS to be a
pointer across you know across all the
elements if you have multiple windows
you can and someone goes to close one of
those windows you can just hide it so
that if you need to show it again you
can just show it instead of recreating
that window that's just a little you
know you I you know UX improvement
instead of you know waiting the cycles
for that window to create again a
poor-man's multi-threading is to offload
work you know some work has to be done
on the main process there's there's no
other way around it but to keep your
your UI responsive maybe if you need to
go and download some stuff from some
api's or check for messages or that kind
of thing you can send an IPC message to
your main process to that's like a
command and say hey go do this and then
send me a message back when you when
you're done and that way you know from a
user's perspective the UI remains really
responsive they can do whatever they
want
then in the background you are going and
doing that that kind of heavy lifting
you know the processing building reports
building files all those kind of things
can be done on the background on the
main process you know question I get
asked a lot is what about local storage
or what about dealing with with
databases and so forth so on local
storage you can certainly because it's
no js' you can read and write json files
i recommend something like FS jetpack or
FS extra that makes it you know even
more easy to read and write javascript
objects to json files you can use
something like any DB which is kind of
like a DB API for reading and
under the covers under the hood it's
it's reading and writing json files but
it presents a MongoDB type API that you
can query documents and you know load
load those things you know insert and
update documents pouch DB is a feature
parity API with CouchDB so you know if
you're comfortable with couch you can
use pouch DB to read and write local
storage the cool thing about pouch DB is
you can synchronize it with a CouchDB
server so in the offline disconected
scenario you can do a bunch of data
entry bunch of work and then when your
application is back online and and can
reconnect with the database it can
synchronize all those documents between
the desktop app and the server because
you're using nodejs anything that's
available to node you can use in your
desktop applications as well so if your
comfort if you want to build a line of
business application that communicates
with messaging systems with relational
databases with all different kinds of
servers and platforms there's modules
available for just about everything you
can imagine and you can you can do that
so
relational database storage side there's
lots of modules available for sequel
server my personal favorite is Siri
there's pg4 postgrads and my sequel
there's Oracle DB so any kind of
relational database that you need to
communicate with there's probably a
module available for that from here
these are some resources that I can
point you to if you search google for
awesome electron you'll come to this
link right here and it is a one-stop
shop of everything electron it's there's
sample applications there's tutorials
there's videos there's reference
applications there's a list of companies
that are using electron it's just
anything in everything imaginable
electron if you have access to plural
site there is a really excellent course
electron fundamentals by Jake Trent that
this is the course I wish I had created
he beat me to it
it's really it really is awesome the
documentation at electron is actually
really good there's a getting started
guide and there's a an easy to get
getting started project that you can
clone and start building your own
application and then there's a nice
electron community on slack where you
can go and ask questions about you know
things that you're running into or you
know and I've always found the electron
community to be really helpful in
welcoming last thing I want to tell you
is that you don't need permission to be
awesome
I really believe that the the technology
that we have at our fingertips enables
us to have a huge impact on our
workplaces in our community and even the
world we have just incredible
opportunity and potential to have a
positive impact on folks and I hope that
the things that you're learning at this
conference that you go back to your your
workplace or whatever it is that you do
next week and you
are able to you know take the things
that you're learning and you be awesome
thank you very much
[Applause]
I have some stickers up here if you're
interested in stickers if you have any
questions I'll be up here you can come
talk to me or come find me out in the in
the hallways or I'll be around all day
today so again Twitter is probably one
of the best ways to keep in contact with
me I'm kind of a loudmouth on Twitter I
tried to be funny and sometimes I
succeed